par ailleurs madame nicole notât de la
cfdt s'est rendu cet après midi à l'
usine de vilvoorde sébastien guibert
dominique merlin reportage
nous avons trois petit camion est comme
ça aussi
une vingtaine de camions et camionnettes
et nous sommes clients chez renault
depuis 1970
les élus de la commune danse près de
liège ont vu leurs 27 années de fidélité
à renault bien mal récompensée l'annoncé
de la fermeture de l'usiné de vilvorde
située à 100 km de là à provoquer ici
surtout de la digne assaut par le
procédé qui a été employé par le pdg
français et pour marquer leur rancoeur
les élus ont annulé la commande d'une
renault espace ils achèteront finalement
leur voiture à un concurrent allemand la
mesure fait des émules
les maires de liège et de namur par
exemple ont décidé d'exclure renault des
prochains appels d'offres pour le
renouvellement de leurs véhicules
municipaux
le ministre de l'intérieur lui a
carrément suspendu l'achat des 300
voitures destinées à la gendarmerie
nationale pour son homologue des
transports ces sanctions ne sont que
symboliques l'essentiel à ses yeux c'est
l'europe sociale
il convient tout d'abord d'avoir des
règles uniformes dans les différents
pays
avoir une meilleure protection sociale
une meilleure protection des
travailleurs c'est évidemment quand on
aura pu mettre tout ça en place qu'on
n'assistera plus à des phénomènes tels
que celui nous venons de connaître
l'europe sociale nicole notât est venu
justement pour en parler ce soir avec
les ouvriers de vilvorde et mettre en
garde les dirigeants de renault
même si cette entreprise connaît les
difficultés si elle doit faire face à
des problèmes économiques
elle n'a pas d'avenir et de performance
économique dans le contre sens social
pas l'un sans l'autre
demain des heurts de débrayages sont
prévus dans plusieurs usines renault en
europe et ce soir monsieur ban